gel hydroalcoolique sens de circulation
nouvelle signalisation au sol port du
masque recommandé le centre-ouest fils
de parly 2 fermée depuis mars a rouvert
ses portes le 29 mai dernier en mettant
en place des mesures sanitaires pour
lutter contre le coc vide 19 une
réorganisation inédite pour répondre aux
demandes des autorités
tout est clair et chaque boutique a pris
ses dispositions le centre aussi donc
non ce en toute sécurité
ça nous change un peu nos habitudes ou
mais au moins pu faire sans se rentrent
dedans c'est très bien vu les
circonstances dans ce moment c'est
parfait c'est parfait on a des seins en
charge de la sécurité
non c'est bien je pense que tout le
monde s'est adapté à cette situation et
à cette crise qu'elle on doit s'adapter
faire preuve d'agilité et je pense que
les visiteurs sont d'abord très content
de revenir à oui s'il parlait d'eux et
ils prennent eux mêmes déjà leurs
précautions en venant donc c'est une
bonne nouvelle
dans le centre la quasi-totalité des
boutiques ont rouvert progressivement
175 en scène sur 183 accueille
aujourd'hui les clients les habitudes
des consommateurs ont quant à elles
évolué depuis leur retour un autre qu'on
a beaucoup moins de promeneurs dans le
nord-ouest fil par l'idée aujourd'hui en
revanche pas là quand ils viennent ce
qu'on a c'est que ils viennent pour
acheter et de ce que nos enseignes nous
disent depuis la réouverture vendredi
dernier c'est que le taux de
transformation est très bon et les
paniers moyens sont sont plus élevés que
d'habitude
le centre espère maintenant une
réouverture du cinéma le 22 juin
prochain toujours en respectant les
règles sanitaires